Aww Yeah! You asked for it!
Let's learn English with Guns N' Roses!
So, Guns N' Roses is, of course,
an iconic '80s band, and for today's lesson,
we've chosen one of their most popular
songs, Sweet Child O' Mine,
which is great for learning
intermediate grammar and vocabulary.
Now, do you want to understand your
favorite music, movies, series and more?
Well, we'll help you to do it without getting lost
without missing the jokes,
and without subtitles.
Just like Sophie, who says that along
with our music lessons,
she has improved her English in just two months.
You can too — all you have to do is
hit that subscribe button and the bell down below,
to not miss any of our new lessons.
Now, let's rock and roll with Guns N' Roses.
Hey! Real quick — do you want to master
native pronunciation, vocabulary, and even grammar?
Well, the most fun way to do it
is with our Fluent with Friends course,
and today you can try it for FREE with
our 3-Part Master Class.
So, I want to give you three reasons why
you should try out this 3-Part Master Class:
The first one is VOCABULARY — you will
learn tons of vocabulary,
and not just vocabulary that
you never use and you forget,
but the vocabulary that natives
really use  every single day,
and, we'll also show you how to never forget it.
The second reason is because of
PRONUNCIATION —
you will learn the way that natives really speak —
not at all like how you learned in school.
And, the third reason is because you will learn
the CULTURAL CONTEXT,
so that you will be able to understand
and laugh along with every single joke.
And, in addition to all of this,
if you join our full Fluent with Friends course,
you will never be alone in your learning because you get to join our global community of English learners,
the Fluency Circle.
So, what are you waiting for?
You can try that all for free with our 3-part masterclass
by clicking up here
or down in the description below.
Hey! If you're enjoying this lesson
with Guns N' Roses,
well, you are bound to find another lesson
with songs that you'll enjoy in this playlist.
You can check that out by clicking up here, or down
in the description below after you finish this lesson.